today on the matt walsh show a trans
psychologist is now raising concerns
about the rush to transition children
he's concerned about it even though he
is still doing the thing he's concerned
about also the left continues in its
hilarious panic attack over elon musk
potentially buying twitter and a woman
celebrates her abortion with a cake and
a party whatever happened to safe legal
and rare plus in our daily cancellation
a new poll says that millennials and gen
z are leaving their jobs in pursuit of
happiness so why are they still so
unhappy we'll talk about all that and
more today on the matt wells show
[Music]
you know when you start uh when you
speak out in defense of life and defense
of children you are going to get
a lot of backlash and outrage some
people on the left have been saying that
the pro-life people in texas and the
other growing number of states with a
heartbeat act are no better than the
taliban they ignore science and biology
and refuse to acknowledge that
heartbeats are actually a good thing
insults like you're the taliban it's all
there they have left to say this is why
our friends at 40 days for life wrote
the number two amazon christian
bestseller
what to say when the complete new guide
to discussing abortion how to change
minds and convert hearts in a brave new
world 40 days for life is based in texas
and it's one of the largest pro-life
grassroot organizations in the world
they have one million volunteers in a
thousand cities in 64 countries holding
peaceful 40-day vigils outside of
abortion facilities to save lives and
help abortion workers leave their jobs
you can get the book
what to say when today in fact i wrote
the forward for it so that's one reason
to buy it but really the real reason is
just a great book and it gives you all
the arguments and all the responses to
the other side's arguments covers the
old arguments and the new ones that you
might be hearing at work or with family
so get it now and check out
40daysforlife.com to help end abortion
wherever you live
well many on the right were pleased this
week when dr erica anderson a clinical
psychologist
raised concerns about the epidemic of
teens identifying as transgender
anderson is trans himself a male who
identifies as a woman
and has um as his la times profile puts
it helped hundreds of teens transition
throughout his career
helped we've really got to put that word
in quotes but now he has concerns and
we're supposed to cheer him for blowing
the whistle i guess but i'm not quite in
the mood to applaud people like this i
have to confess reading now from the
times article it says day after day
emails pour into erica anderson's inbox
from parents struggling to support their
teenagers coming out as transgender
the parents come to anderson 71 in part
because she herself is transgender
anderson also stands out because she
again she is i'm reading quoting from
the article these are the incorrect
words they're using in the article
is one of the few clinical psychologists
specializing in transgender youth to
publicly question the sharp rise in
adolescents coming out as trans or
non-binary she has helped hundreds of
teens transition but she also has comes
to believe that some children
identifying as trans are falling under
the influence of their peers and social
media and that some clinicians are
failing to subject minors to rigorous
mental health evaluations
before recommending hormones or
surgeries
uh you think
i mean some of us have been saying this
for years
this was immediately obvious to some of
us from the very beginning and yet it
took anderson years and hundreds of teen
transitions before it finally dawned on
him that
maybe there's a problem here
this is a licensed trained clinical
psychologist
and yet the social contagion possibility
only recently occurred to him
back to the article it says i think it's
gone too far said anderson who until
recently led the u.s professional
society at the forefront of transgender
care
quote for a while we were all happy that
society was becoming more accepting and
more families than ever were embracing
children that were gender variant now
it's got to the point where there are
kids presenting at clinics whose parents
say this just doesn't make sense
her skepticism and her willingness to
speak directly to the public puts her at
the center of america's culture war over
trans kids
but this skepticism um has not stopped
anderson from still participating
in the transitioning of children
as the time times notes quote
anderson's website promises to help you
become your authentic self
and her twitter bio proclaims working
for a radically inclusive world for all
transgender people
some cases are relatively
straightforward after a year of weekly
conversations with liz a 15 year old who
had no mental health issues and had long
questioned her gender before she came
out as a girl
well let's stop there for a second had
no mental health issues
and had long questioned her gender his
gender i think we're talking about a boy
no mental
health issues and had long questioned
his gender
that that's like saying uh well you know
he had no uh problems with his physical
health
and also he had lung cancer
like that that is the mental health
issue
but it says that anderson wrote a letter
of support this year for a puberty
blocker implant and estrogen patches for
this
young boy
apparently um anderson sees himself as
quite moderate on the issue though as
he's quoted quote
the people on the right and on the left
don't see themselves as extreme but
those of us who see all the nuance can
see that this is a false binary let it
all happen without a method or don't let
any pass
both are wrong
now the real scary thing here is that in
fact
anderson does represent moderation in
comparison to the rest of his field
the times mentions how wpath which is uh
stands for the world professional
association for transgender health
propose new standards of care for kids
and those these are the the new ones are
proposed in december
and the new standards of care are uh
minimum age of 14 for hormone therapy 15
for chest masculine masculinization and
17 for genital surgeries
and only after comprehensive assessments
showing patients meet the diagnostic
criteria of gender incongruence and
demonstrate persistent gender
incongruence or non-conformity for
several years
okay so
they will still drug kids as young as 14
they'll still chop the breasts off of 15
year old girls that's the euphemism
masculinization otherwise known as
chopping body parts off
and they'll still generally mutilate
minors
they're still going to do that and yet
many trans affirming doctors and
psychologists say that even those
standards are too strict not affirming
enough
what they want is
nothing they want no guidelines no
standards
no rules at all
anderson supports at least some
standards
and thus qualifies as not only moderate
but really downright conservative in
comparison
to the frankenstein psychopaths in his
field or i should say the other
frankenstein psychopaths
because anderson even while raising
concerns
has participated in this kind of
unthinkable abuse hundreds of times
and is still doing it even now in spite
of all of his concerns
now
i don't mean to downplay or say that
it's
insignificant
for someone like this to come out and
concede that there's a problem it is
indeed quite significant
and it should tell you something that
even a trans psychologist who
transitions children
is willing to admit that there are some
red flags here at least
that's significant i just don't give
them any credit is my point
it should again be immediately obvious
self-evident
to anyone with the slightest
understanding of child psychology that
kids are not mentally equipped to make
these kinds of decisions and
that kids are extremely susceptible to
peer pressure
so if if lots of minors are all at once
making this kind of decision that should
tell you all you need to know
if some of the medical professionals
responsible for fomenting this confusion
and helping to spread the social
contagion are now suddenly concerned
it's not because they give the slightest
dam about the well-being of kids
it's because they're performing another
medical procedure called cya
in the medical field cover your ass
but but here's the important point
anderson still obviously affirms trans
ideology at its core
here he is for example in a recent video
on his youtube channel
giving some advice to uh to trans people
listen
i often talk with my patients about the
voice in our head that's self-critical
and what we need to do is we need to
address that self-criticism and realize
that what we're doing is is
extraordinary that to live an authentic
life as a trans person requires a lot of
bravery
and not to discount that
and if we do that if we are really
authentic in knowing who we are and
believing in our journey
people will come along sooner or later
and not all people will come along but
it won't matter because we're living our
authentic life
and that's what's most important
yeah it's uh really someone you want to
go to for your mental health troubles
now it doesn't matter
how many concerns you raise about the
rush to transition children
those concerns mean nothing if you're
still telling the story that we hear in
that clip
a story where authenticity can be found
by rejecting your true physical
biological divinely created nature and
reaching for some figment some phantom
version of yourself even to the point of
carving up your body to align with it
after all the whole reason why we should
not rush to transition children
is not that they aren't ready for it
but rather that nobody at any age is
ready for it
because it is an impossibility we
shouldn't rush to transition kids we
also we also shouldn't transition them
slowly or carefully shouldn't transition
them at all
and even more so you we can't
you actually can't transition kids from
one sex to another you can't transition
adults either
but you can drug them and mutilate them
because you cannot become something
other than what you biologically are
the problem with trans ideology isn't
that
it's too nuanced or too mature or too
complicated for children to fully
understand
that's not the problem
the problem is that it's false
and because it's false it is dangerous
now
if trans ideology were not false
then you could probably make an argument
for transitioning teens if it weren't
false i mean if it's true that a male
can be born in the wrong body
if it's true that your authentic self
could be something other than your
physical self then
why should we prevent teenagers from
embracing and living that truth
the argument against transitioning
children becomes incoherent pretty
quickly or at the very least it becomes
much much much weaker
if it's not based in a fundamental
rejection of trans ideology as a whole
the entire thing
and that's why someone like erica
anderson for as long as he perpetuates
the ideology will always be part of the
problem not the solution
because there's no middle ground here
there is no moderate stance there's no
in between
position
this is not a both sides are wrong kind
of thing
one side is wrong
it's the side that tells people whatever
their age
that authenticity and happiness can be
found in a rejection of their natural
self
it's a side that tells people whatever
their age
that it's possible to transition
from one sex to another
that that gender is fluid that
that's that's the side that's wrong
that's where all the wrongness lives
now over on that wrong side there there
may be degrees of wrongness
some are even wronger than others
even more dogmatic in their wrongness
more dedicated to it more extreme even
but they're all wrong
the whole side the whole ideology
we have to reject it all every piece of
it
that's the only way
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right let's uh start here it's from
the daily wire
twitter ceo prague agrawal tried to calm
the company's employees during an
emergency all hands meeting today
as they are this is yesterday as they
panicked over the possibility that elon
musk will buy the company outright
um
agarwal reportedly told nervous
employees that musk could not change the
company's culture because
no one man can change that now this is
this is significant but it sounds like
he's preparing them at least for the
possibility that that musk might
actually pull this off and buy the
company
um
it says while he is legally limited to
what he can disclose about the situation
it's an interesting choice of words as
it appears to leave open the possibility
that musk really may take over the
company and turn it private um
one twitter employee tried to claim that
musk
uh that what musk was doing by trying to
buy the company for far above market
value was like a hostage situation
agawal said i don't believe we're being
held hostage
he said this provides all of us with
this moment where we feel distracted
where we feel a loss of control
i'm personally going to spend my time
focusing on things i can control
and that i believe will
matter so they had kind of a
oh man i would have loved actually i
wish we had some clips of this uh this
meeting i would have loved to be
a fly on the wall there to see that
all of the twitter employees panicking
sobbing crying comforting each other
we'll get through this together it's
just what it's so great
this is one of this story is uh one of
my this is one of my favorite stories
one of my favorite this is one of my
favorite news events
of probably the decade it's got
everything you could possibly want
and as we discussed yesterday the fact
that
the man responsible for this elon musk
is an african-american on top of it just
makes it all the much better
now um elon musk meanwhile was at a uh a
ted
talk conference and he was explaining
some of what's going on and why he
decided to do this we'll start here he
was asked why he made this offer to
begin with and let's let's listen
why make that offer oh so
um
well i think it's very important for
uh there to be
an inclusive arena for
free speech uh where
all yeah so uh yeah um
twitter has become kind of the de facto
town square um so
uh
it's just really important that people
have the both the uh the reality and the
perception
uh that they're able to speak freely
within the bounds of the law um
and
you know so one of the things that i
believe twitter should do is open source
the algorithm
and make any changes
uh to people's tweets you know if
they're emphasized or de-emphasized uh
that action should be
made apparent so you can anyone can see
that that action has been taken
so there's no sort of behind-the-scenes
uh manipulation either algorithmically
or
manually um
[Applause]
well you hear on the left that they care
a lot about
inclusivity and that's elon musk's pitch
here is that he wants uh twitter to be
actually inclusive
i mean inclusive in the only way that
that means anything
and also diverse in the only way that
means anything
especially for a social media platform
which is to you know
allow
a diversity of opinion allow people to
express their viewpoints
um
that's what matters on a social media
platform
and that's his pitch that it should be
inclusive
he also says interestingly that he he
doesn't care about the economics of it
that's not what he's in it for let's
listen to that
my
strong intuitive sense is that uh having
a public platform that is maximally
trusted
um and and and
and broadly inclusive
um
is extremely important to the future of
civilization but you've described
yourself i don't care about the
economics at all
[Applause]
um
now meanwhile over the left of course
the panic continues and uh
they're they're very concerned about
the devastating consequences
to to speech and they're trying to dress
this up as well they're worried about
how this is going to affect free speech
even though elon musk's whole point is
that when the reason wants to take over
is that twitter is not protecting free
speech
so over on msnbc they were talking about
um
talk about these devastating
consequences how bad this is going to be
for for the entire world let's hear that
there are real
and devastating consequences for using
that platform to lie and we've seen it
we've seen it happen
i i wonder
you know when talking about this it's
you know it's kind of funny elon musk's
want wants to buy it but they're a
massive
life and globe alter altering
consequences for just letting people run
wild on the thing
yes 100 but that's facebook is really
the way the real action is in that so
that's this is a very small company
people it has an outsized influence
because media people like it politicians
world leaders um and elon musk and so
one of the issues is if he's not going
to do this and by the way twitter and
some of its biggest investors uh like uh
prince alwaleed bin talal are saying no
and they're putting poison pills in um
what is he going to do
he's going to have to somehow unload
this 10 stake um and he probably that's
probably what he's going to have to do
or raise private financing which has its
own risks uh and possible rewards but a
lot of risks for him well i didn't play
the sound bite but he was asked if
there's a plan b and he laughed and said
there is we'll find out what that is
that's what a super villain hero would
say right
he thinks he's tony stark right that's
what they'd say whatever however you
feel about them that's what tony stark
would say
super villain devastating consequences
this was uh
echoed by salon writer matthew rosac we
pulled this up uh he
he's this is this is what he says this
is not supposed to be a joke okay we
play we showed you some of the similar
reactions yesterday on twitter from the
blue check crowd journalists and and
everything
and they really do think that this is
this is a civilizational catastrophe to
have
elon musk on twitter so matthew rosa who
work as writes for salon said if elon
musk allows trump back on twitter it'll
be a death blow to the free world
trump's big lie will spread like a virus
i discuss the danger of trump's big lie
for salon like okay
like hitler's big lie it must not be
normalized lest fascism return so we got
we got it all in there we got fascism we
got hitler the death blow to the free
world that's how much power
trump has
apparently just by trolling twitter
and here's the here's the one of the
many great ironies about this
so that the left
very worried about
what will happen if this billionaire
is uh is able to purchase twitter
you know god forbid a billionaire owns a
social media platform it'd be the first
one first time this ever happened right
but one of many ironies is that first of
all
these journalists
almost every single one of them
work for companies that are owned by
billionaires
jeff bezos owns washington post
and but yet the washington post they're
among
the outlets telling us what what a
crisis this will be for elon musk on
twitter
and then also who who owns twitter right
now
yes we we don't want we don't want it to
fall into the hands of elon musk we want
it to be in the hands of people we trust
people like um
blackrock
the vanguard group
morgan stanley
the saudi royal family
you know how much the saudi royal family
cherishes free speech right
we know the saudi royal family that's
they really care a lot about democracy
and so that's why we need to we need
them
we need them to
keep their stake in in twitter so that
so that democracy will remain intact
it'll be a death blow to the free world
it'll be the death blow to the free
world if the saudi royal family does not
still own a large portion of twitter
and when the saudi prince yesterday said
that he's not going to sell
the left was cheering him on say yes
yes please please
stay invested in twitter so that we know
that we can
that it's in the hands of people we can
trust
asset management firms banks
foreign dictators
a lot better off with with them owning
it right rather than an african-american
immigrant
you damned racists
all right um ron desantis yesterday
signed a late-term abortion ban this has
been just a great
week
for for the pro-life cause we've got
abortion bans in uh oklahoma and
kentucky
and now in
florida they signed uh this is not an uh
unfortunately this is not an abortion
ban that covers all abortions but does
cover a lot of them there's a late-term
abortion ban
and uh ron desantis signed it in front
of a very excited crowd yesterday and
also gave a shout out we got to play
this because he gave a shout out to um
daily wire and one of our great
reporters daily wire let's listen to
that
so you see how
that type of mindset has led to
things that really shock the conscience
in our society we just saw
this terrible scandal in washington dc
oh yeah do we we where is mary margaret
here from the daily wire
there's mary margaret she did this great
uh expose
they found
all these remains of babies and they
found five who were basically infants
premature they would have been but they
would have been able to survive you know
outside the womb and yet washington dc
is treating that
just like we would treat the trash from
our lunch or something like that
it's really horrifying to see that that
could go on in our country but
particularly in our nation's capital and
so that is callous
that is wrong and i want to thank her
and daily wire for exposing that
[Applause]
um yeah mary margaret's done a lot of
great work there uh it's also live
action and uh of course the pro-life
activists in dc who expose us to begin
with now i said it's been a great week
for the pro-life cause and it has been
um but on the negative side of things
last week anyway is um
i mean it's it's the fact that this
story came out last week and already
it's been buried i mean the corporate
media buried it right away they never
had any interest in it
but um
it's it's already like a distant memory
um the fact that
that
fully developed infants were butchered
in dc
and the police are refusing to do an
autopsy refusing to conduct any
investigation whatsoever
um
this is it becomes difficult even if
you're on the right side of the issue
and you care about it
it's there there are so many things
going on all at once
you know one of one of our big
challenges that we have on the right i
think it's challenging everybody has
but just speaking about uh on the right
one of our challenges is to remain
focused on issues that matter when we
have an issue it's really important to
remain focused on not getting distracted
by other things
um
so that's not something we can't just
let that go
that oh they're murdering fully
developed infants in dc and
law enforcement is helping to cover it
up you don't just let that go and move
on
and certainly the daily wire we're not
going to let it go um so that was great
from desantis meanwhile nikki fryed is
the agriculture commissioner and she's
running for governor
as a democrat and she spoke out about
this ban she was very upset about it so
i want you to remember the footage you
just saw ron desantis in front of a a
large cheering excited crowd
and here is his primary challenger on
the democrat side um and uh let's let's
watch
something very sad this happened today
um
moments ago governor sanchez described
the abortion ban in our state
so uh
that's why we have to win
we have to win because he just moved us
back 50 years
all right ron desantis has got to be
shaking in his boots looking at that
this is a formidable challenge i counted
what about 10 people in the crowd there
she's at a parking lot talking to 10
people
this is a
that
that turnout that makes biden's turnouts
that makes like a biden campaign event
look like a trump event in comparison
so pretty sad speaking of sad um and
disgusting and infuriating uh also
someone who goes by carmelita hate
appropriate last name calls herself a
professional [ __ ] that's what she calls
herself and i'm not gonna quibble with
that description at all um anyway she
tweeted this
viral this week
abortion is healthcare and also
traumatic so if you do have one please
gather all of your closest friends after
to celebrate be around endless love and
happiness for your decision
thanks for everyone who came last night
and um
apparently she had a party to celebrate
her abortion and then she has a picture
of a cake and it says originally it's a
boy but the y is crossed out to spell uh
it's aborted
and then
you know people
as you might expect reacted to this
um
in a not so positive way and so she was
she kind of responded to the backlash
she says is it crazy that i posted this
kinda
but to stop making abortion some
shameful secret in people's lives maybe
some crazy stuff is what they need to
see i'm thankful to have such a good
support system and good sense of humor
to get through the tough stuff
and that's that on that
eloquent as always
now there are a couple of uh
things to note here
first of all as always
we see how the
safe legal and rare mantra
has long since gone away i mean there
was a time
and maybe if you're a little bit younger
you might not even remember this time
because this is this was back
mostly in the 90s
you know but when i'm coming of age and
first became introduced
to the uh issue of abortion
back then
the people on the pro-abortion side
said that you know we we don't like
abortion either nobody likes abortion um
we just want it to be we want it to be
safe which is a misnomer because there's
no such thing as a safe abortion because
it's always killing at least one person
and uh it's always damaging the second
person which is the mother whether
physically oftentimes physically but
certainly psychologically and
emotionally whether she wants to face up
to that damage right away or not
but that's what they said we want a safe
abortion we want it legal
and uh we want it to be rare we you know
we don't we don't want a lot of
abortions
it's just um it's a kind of a it's a
necessary evil that was sort of the
approach
back in the 90s
well now all that's gone away well legal
is still there they still want it to be
legal
they want abortion to every stage to be
legal
and they still talk about safe abortions
which don't exist but um
rare is out the window
because the problem is
if you
if you admit that you want abortion to
be rare
then you are admitting that there's that
it's not a good thing
you're at least conceding that it's less
than ideal to be murdering babies let's
say
and they're not going to concede that
and so that gives rise to the shout your
abortion movement and all this stuff and
people going out of their way to
celebrate it you know
though even when they celebrate it
you can still tell the truth because she
even says uh abortion is healthcare and
it's traumatic
and then she talks about how it's it's
it feels uh shameful it's a shameful
secret
well hang on a second
how is it traumatic
i mean why why would abortion be
traumatic
if it's if it's just a clump of cells
if it's not a human being that you're
killing then what's traumatizing about
it
and if if even more than that you are
it's a statement of your
autonomy and your liberty as a woman
then there's nothing traumatic
i mean i
the way that they talk about abortion
it's like in fact they will quite
literally compare it to
um having a parasite removed
or you have a tapeworm or something and
you go to the doctor and get medicine
for it
or having a having a cancerous lump
taken off of your body
well who would ever describe that as as
traumatic
it might be traumatic to have the cancer
but but you know being free of an
illness that's not a in and of itself
traumatic
um
so it doesn't make a lot of sense
according to the narrative that they
give us
but then it starts to make a lot of
sense when you realize that uh of course
abortion is killing a human child and
that even these women they they still
know that
that's still in the back of their minds
in their subconscious and probably not
even buried that deep
because when you see all of this
celebration of abortion and where to
throw a party for our for the abortion
um yeah it's disgusting and it's it's
enraging to see
and um these people are psychopaths in a
lot of ways but you also have to
understand
they're not trying to convince us of
anything
they're trying to convince themselves
this is um
you know this is overcompensation
to a maximum degree
because
you know
this is this is the truth about abortion
that i'm that i'm always trying to get
across is that you know
despite what the abortion industry tells
women
you can't just go get the abortion and
then it's like what they what they tell
the women is it's like said it's like
hitting the reset button
and going back
you were going to have a child
but um you decided to get abortion and
now so now there's no child anymore and
you can go back to how it was before
it's like it's like turning the clock
back it's it's magical it's like
resetting
taking an eraser to a chalkboard
but that's not actually what it is
because
you are still a mother you become a
mother the moment you conceive a child
and so you are killing your child
and now you are the mother of a dead
child
and that is the reality that will always
be with you
and you could try to stave off the
mourning process you could try to stave
off the trauma
um you could try to stave off the guilt
by going over the top and getting the
confetti out and setting off fireworks
but eventually
it will it will come through and you're
gonna have to face it
okay two other quick things to mention
here this is from the daily mail it says
two women in new jersey's only
all-women's prison have both fallen
pregnant after having sex with
transgender inmates
the pregnant women who were not
identified are housed at the embattled
edna mahan
correctional facility in clinton which
new jersey governor announced plans to
close last year prison bosses said that
in both instances the sex was consensual
it is unclear if the women had sex with
the same transgender inmate or if it was
two different inmates
so already we have we need a snopes fact
check here well not a snopes fact check
because they're not going to fact-check
something like this but this is not an
all-women's prison apparently
that's kind of cool that's that's uh
that's
that's hard to figure out it's an
all-women's prison and and women are
falling pregnant how does that happen
well because it's not all women's um
edna mahan houses 27 transgender
prisoners
and over 800 women all together
it is also unclear how far along the two
inmates are and whether they plan to
continue with their respective
pregnancies
whether they plan to continue there's
another euphemism for you um an
investigation has been launched so
there's a women's prison
800 women
and they already have almost 30 men in
the women's prison
and i can also without without knowing
anything about the the particulars here
and i don't know that i fully even
believe the particulars that we're being
told
like we're just told that the sex was
consensual i mean maybe it was
but listen there's no reason to believe
that whatsoever
you're taking violent criminal men
oftentimes like rapists and sex
offenders
who are in prison as men and then one
day say you know what i'm actually a
woman
and they're they're sexually attracted
to women and so this is all just just
kind of a happy coincidence
that now they get to be housed with
women
uh you're taking them you're locking
them into cages with actual women
and then
if a woman
becomes pregnant in fact some of the
headlines there was one headline it
might have been in the daily mail or one
of these other outlets it said that uh
two women have fallen pregnant
at a women's prison they've fallen
pregnant
yeah what are they falling on exactly
that's not that's not something that's a
that's something that happens after a
particular act now whether that act was
consensual that's my point is
there's no reason to believe that
um
because we are not going to be told
if a trans male rapes a female inmate
that information is not going to make it
to us through any official channels they
would never tell us that
i mean and even if it was
supposedly on the surface consensual
when you when you put a woman
in a in in a prison cell
with a violent dangerous man
and the woman quote chooses to have sex
with the man
is that actually consent is there a real
choice there
i mean we we've been told by the me too
movement that um if a woman chooses to
have sex with her boss that it's not
really a choice there's not really any
consent there
or not as much consent as there should
be because of the power power dynamics
at play
so you're a woman locked in a cell
with a man who could overpower you at
any
and who is sexually attracted to females
and you have sex with them is that is is
it even a choice
or is it something these women are doing
just out of self-preservation
so i don't no matter how you slice i'm
not sure how you can even call it
consensual
and if they've got 30 male prisoners in
in a in this one women's prison in new
jersey
um
this is this
we're talking about hundreds if not
thousands of men who are in women's
prisons right now
and again they're they're violent and
dangerous that's why they're in prison
so as i've been saying for a long time
this is um
i i guarantee you
there is right now an epidemic of sexual
assaults by men against women in women's
prisons and it's happening right now and
we will we will never be told about it
though
because these women have no way of
telling us
and of course the me too movement is uh
conspicuously silent about the whole
thing let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
let's see the uh sean speck says that
title alone probably called for at least
2 000 outraged liberals and leftists to
scream out loud so thank you for that
that has made my week the title of the
show yesterday with it elon musk as an
african-american immigrant like i said
it will never not be funny
one of the many things that makes this
story just
so incredible
um another comment says your discussion
talking through this what's the plan
here situation when choosing to fight
the cops
makes it so painfully clear that all of
these young men grew up without fathers
because your point of view is exactly
what any good father would say i've
heard similar things for my own dad
think things through before you act
consider the consequences use the brain
that's in your head fatherlessness is
literally killing people well of course
it is killing lots of people
it's killing um the people who grow up
without fathers
it's killing
the people who those fatherless
criminals then go on to victimize
killing a lot of people
and you're exactly right i had the same
thought
because as a father i i'm constantly
having this conversation with my own
kids
they do something that doesn't make any
sense and i have to sit them down and
say okay what what were you hoping would
it would happen here what was what
walk me through the steps
that's what you're supposed to do as a
father
it's about imparting just a little bit
of common sense
because it turns out that common sense
doesn't um especially for kids
doesn't always come naturally
you've got to kind of condition them
into common sense and being able to
think rationally
and being able to think like being able
to think through an action
where you say okay i'm going to do this
and here are the potential results of
this particular action
that's not something that kids are
naturally good at they need parents
there and i think especially fathers to
walk them through it and then if you
have kids who never get that because
they have no father at home
then they grow up and next thing you
know as happened with the most recent
blm martyr
you know he stopped by the police
he runs away
and the next thing you know he's in he's
in this this hand-to-hand battle with
the cops and there's just nothing good
that can come of it there is no positive
outcome
imaginable
even if you're able to fight the cops
off and run away
when they catch you you're going to go
to jail for longer now
but the moment you start fighting the
cops especially if you're grabbing at
their weapons even if it's the taser
your chances of now being killed in this
um interaction have just increased
tenfold
and you know what it's it's in
an unwillingness or inability to think
through your actions and use some common
sense but i also think at a deeper level
uh you find people who who just there's
this despair there they don't they don't
see their life as having any value
and so if the black lives matter
movement
could serve any purpose at all and if it
actually cared about black lives
it wouldn't be screaming at us like you
don't need to scream at me that black
lives matter i know that i never said
anything otherwise
but instead maybe you should tell that
to
someone like the most recent
blm martyr who was uh
you know uh
who was killed while while fighting the
cops
like that's a message that he needs to
hear needed to hear before it was too
late about himself your life has value
you know value your own life
protect your own life by not making
these kinds of decisions
self-destructive decisions
um
let's see jason says love the show matt
but i feel it's time for a little
constructive criticism i'm sure you're
right about dr oz and the position he
holds
but that felt like a lack of context
um was that video you played with
justice millett pre the facts coming out
did he change his tune afterwards felt a
little judgy to me
just saying i don't like the idea of
bagging on the guy who admittedly i
would likely despise as well using a
video that i'm guessing was before the
juicy scandal blew up and no context as
to where he stands now it was referring
to uh
of all the damning video clips you can
play of dr oz is just the the latest one
to resurface was him
after um
the justice millett hoax was perpetrated
him him supporting jesse small talking
about what a great guy he is well first
of all
speaking of common sense
it was obvious to anybody with common
sense immediately that that story was
was false
um and and also dr oz is running for
office now as a politician so there's no
being yeah judgey of a political
candidate sure
you know that's there's
i don't think it's possible actually to
go overboard in our skepticism towards
and um
criticism of political candidates
oftentimes i think we go the other
direction but we're not skeptical enough
so you want to run for office then you
have to endure that kind of criticism
especially when you have
made a career
over um
sending false falsehoods out into the
world
the only thing about that justice
millett clip is like we don't even need
to focus on that because of i don't
think we need to get past the fact that
the first clip we played last week of of
dr oz endorsing trans kids
or abortion or gun control or any of the
rest of it
and yet he's still got the uh donald
trump endorsement of course
well as you know the daily wire is
intent on changing the culture which is
why we're actively changing it in
literally every way possible and now
we've started our own publishing wing
called dw books and we're proud to
publish books that actively fight the
left's monopoly on storytelling like
fiery but mostly peaceful the 2020 riots
and the gaslighting of america by julio
rosas who pulls back the curtain on the
black lives matter riots and the
movement that broke out across the
country in the aftermath of george
floyd's death rosas who was reporting
from the ground gives us first-hand
experience and exposes the media's
attempts to convince americans that the
fatal and destructive riots were
peaceful check out the trailer
the media gasoline the american people
for all of 2020 as the riots unfolded
they did not give you the full story i
was there
joe floyd kyle rittenhouse rachard books
jazz in seattle i saw all the riots with
my own eyes windshields being smashed
giant rocks that were being from
businesses that were starting to be
looted the crowd started to become
hostile
all the cops were trapped and surrounded
police were being ordered to to retreat
i experienced the tear gas i experienced
the smoke this was very real to me
the mainstream media they were trying to
call them protests cnn with that chiron
saying fiery but mostly peaceful they're
trying to push a narrative of don't
believe your lying eyes because they
were trying to appease a very dedicated
antifa movement that's there we read my
book fiery but mostly peaceful you will
get the full story you will learn what
actually happened during the riots of
2020 and what the media did not want to
tell you buy my book fiery but mostly
peaceful everywhere books are sold
the book is available for pre-order on
amazon or anywhere you buy books online
so go pre-order your copy today now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
recently for the daily cancellation we
spent some time
dumping on boomers after jeff foxworthy
tried to blame the younger generations
for the existence of participation
trophies and as i pointed out the
boomers label millennials the
participation trophy generation
are neglecting to mention that they the
boomers are the ones who invented
participation trophies and gave them out
in fact the boomers invented almost all
of the terrible things that are ripping
our society apart things like veganism
the internet
the sexual revolution
i don't know if boomer's actually
invented veganism but i'm blaming him
for it anyway but today we're gonna
we're gonna take the always enjoyable
generational blame game and move it over
to the younger set this time gen z and
millennials my generation technically
though from a spiritual and emotional
perspective i'm really more of a
disgruntled 85 year old hermit who lives
in a hollowed-out tree in the woods or
something i don't really identify with
my generation and this yahoo news
article reminds me why here's the
headline
gen z and millennials are disrupting the
workplace as they're choosing to be
jobless rather than work for a company
they don't like
now there are different ways to be a
disrupter you could be the elon musk
type of disrupter doing new and bold
things
challenging the powerful institutions
innovating
or you could be the kind of disruptor
who disrupts by standing off to the side
like a useless lump and scratching your
ass while everyone else gets the work
done
sadly many of my peer group and younger
have chosen the latter course
so the article says quote gen z and
millennials are unique when it comes to
demanding a work-life balance they don't
just want flexible work hours and
environments they want to work for
companies that align with their own
personal beliefs and values and almost
half of gen z millennials would rather
be unemployed than unhappy in a job
according to a new study the career
goals of gen z and millennials are
changing power dynamics in the workplace
almost two and four members of younger
generations would prefer being
unemployed then work in a job they don't
like according to the study most of the
young people surveyed said they
preferred to work at companies that
shared their personal values
two and five gen zers and millennials
said they they would take a lower paying
salary if it meant that they were
purposefully contributing to the society
diversity and inclusion were also
important to the survey respondents
forty nine percent of gianzine 46
percent of millennials said that they
wouldn't work for a company that didn't
make diversity a priority
uh priority of gen z millennials is
their own happiness in fact 56 percent
of gen z and 55 millennials so they
would quit a job if it interfered with
their personal lives
now there's obviously nothing wrong with
wanting to work for a company that
represents your values i mean in
principle that's a very good thing the
problem is in the perverse and stupid
value system that so many of these
people want companies to align with as
evidenced by their insistence on
diversity and inclusion
aside from value alignment
we're also told that millennials and gen
z demand a better work-life balance that
they would rather be unemployed than
unhappy at their jobs and this this is
where the real problems arise i think
first of all
if you're a young person today or even
an old person
the balance you should be worried about
is not work life but screen life
we're told that young people don't want
to work don't want work to interfere
with their personal lives
but almost every waking hour of their
personal lives are wasted staring at
screens anyway
i could have more respect for the desire
for work-life balance if you were going
to home to be you know with your spouse
and children or you were
um
uh trying to leave yourself time to
engage in a productive hobby like
woodworking or gardening or something
but the fact is that for many of these
people the lives they're trying to
protect from workplace intrusion
are hardly lives at all
there's something quite morbidly ironic
about a man screaming that there's more
to his life than being a wage slave
only to discover that the only thing he
wants to do is scroll through tick tock
and binge netflix
second even leaving that issue to the
side
the more fundamental problem with the
work life balance idea is that work and
life
are not two separate things
life is work it's a symptom of our
privilege and entitlement in the modern
industrialized west that we can even
consider life and work as two distinct
categories talk to anybody outside of
that bubble about their work life
balance and they'll have no idea what
you're even talking about
because life requires work every life is
sustained by work
so when the self-righteous millennial or
genzir turns up his nose and says i'd
rather be unemployed than unhappy
working
the question is then
who
will be doing the work to sustain his
existence
whether you're happy or not the fact of
life is that your life requires work and
if you refuse to do it somebody else has
to so who's that going to be your
parents
johnny taxpayer next door
maybe a combination
whoever it is if
you are not you are not living a life
free of the work requirement nobody can
you are rather living a life where that
requirement has been offloaded to
somebody else
you've made someone else your slave in
effect you don't want to be a wage slave
so someone else is going to be your safe
nothing nothing noble about that
it's entitled it's selfish in fact it's
evil
the refusal to participate in the
difficult aspects of your own life
is evil
it's a shameful thing
third point we hear that um
all of these younger people are
prioritizing their happiness focusing on
their happiness
giving up work for the sake of happiness
pursuing happiness thinking about their
happiness talking about happiness
obsessing over their happiness and yet
shockingly so few of them are actually
happy
there have never been people who who
talk so much about happiness and yet
feel it so so little
isn't that interesting
millennials in gen z are at once the
most focused on their happiness and and
yet also the least happy
perhaps there's a lesson there which we
might consider finally learning at some
point
and the lesson is that happiness cannot
be conjured out of the ether like a
magical spell you can't will yourself
into it you can't convince yourself to
be it
happiness is a byproduct
of a well-ordered well-situated grounded
virtuous productive life
that's the only way to achieve sustained
happiness
you can find pleasure outside of that
you can you know go to a back alley
somewhere buy some black tar heroin and
find some pleasure that way i guess you
could derive pleasure from an
extra-large
fast-food value meal or a three dollar
hooker
but you won't find happiness any of
those places
and you won't find it in a directionless
life free of work free of challenge
spent staring at screens while somebody
else provides for all of your many needs
as it turns out life and work cannot be
severed and neither can happiness and
work
it takes work to be happy you have to do
difficult things you have to exert
yourself you have to
give yourself over to some cause beyond
yourself
happiness comes then as a side effect
often when you least expect it
and always when you aren't thinking
about it
you simply fulfill your responsibilities
you live your life you do your work
and one day you look up and you say wow
look at that i'm i'm
happy that's how happiness works
you only find it when you stop looking
for it
this is one of the fundamental facts of
life and it's something that both the
gen z and millennial generations would
do well to learn until then
they are
of course canceled and we'll leave it
there for today thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great
weekend talk to you on monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin